So, now that we seen Amdahl's law, let's do a
quiz. Let's say we have a program with 50 billion
instructions it executes. Let's say that we have a processor
clocked at two gigahertz. Let's say that we improved the branch
instruction so that it no longer takes four cycles to
do one. Now it takes only two cycles to do one.
This is a table where we show for each of
the four instruction types, integer, branches, loads, and stores, the percentage
of all instructions in the program that are of this type. So, for example 40% of
all instructions that we execute are integer instructions.
20% of all instructions that we execute are branch
instructions. 30% are loads, and 10% are stores.
And finally we have the CPI for each
of these types of instructions. For integer it's
one, for branches it was four. The improvement reduces
that to two. Loads spend two cycles
per instruction and stores spend three cycles per
instruction. The question for you is, what is
the overall speedup, which you will answer here.